how much fun was it playing ahead in
santa clarita diet
okay um
so
i i did the first season of santa
clarita diet i did a couple episodes
there had a wonderful time i was really
dying to work with uh tim oliphant and
drew barrymore it was something i
really really wanted to do wow and uh i
was able to do it and had had a
wonderful time were they kind oh my gosh
was timothy kind like you can't even
believe really better than you'd hope
was one of those guys
wow and drew
so sweet
so sweet how long did you work on the
show
oh a couple episodes two maybe two
threes and you had a blast had a great
time had a great day had a great day i
like it um i like hearing that coming
back
they had
pre-filmed all the scenes with a little
dummy head
and then i got all this makeup done to
look like a a a bodyless head and then
sat in a
structure that held my head in place
you had a couple cameras on me and they
ran the scenes and i did my lines
against the pre-filmed
scenes
so it was just me in this weird chair
with my head restricted
and you can't even move your head
i realize as an actor i
i move my head
i move my head quite a bit it's a bit of
a crutch were you claustrophobic at all
not claustrophobic no you're not closed
in it's just that you you can't move
you're just kind of limited to what you
can do were you sitting there going do i
look stupid does this look right it just
sucked a bit of the
process and the fun out of it it was
that's all that's all it was just wasn't
was it great
as as a product yes i think it worked
out really great and glad they included
me but uh it was
not nearly as fun as the first season
drew seems like someone who would mess
up a lot of their lines and just have
fun with it and just laugh a lot
huh no she seemed to be
more
prepared in trying nuances and she she
was really into her character and she
would try little
fine little
pieces and wonderful little melodies and
uh yeah she she she's harder working
than she is forgetful is she easy to
have a crush on you can understand why
people have crushes on her my god yeah
yeah yeah she's instantly like oh my
gosh
crushable yeah but because she's so kind
too she's kind to everybody she knows
everybody's names that's so important i
have a feeling you know everybody's name
too that's one of the things you really
really try to do you know i'm trying to
do i always hates the new guy too
do you too yeah the new camera operator
whoever it is
they go hey i'm dale david nice to meet
you what do you do for us oh i'm gonna
be the new
such and such oh great welcome i'm
really glad you're here i think you're
gonna have a good time hey everybody new
guy looked me right in the eyes and
everybody goes oh what are you doing
yeah we're gonna need new dave
remember when you would fart every time
you could on set yes and everyone loved
it yes yeah remember when you used to
wear sandals and shorts because they
were only shooting you from the waist up
because it was too warm remember when
you had big feet i i
yes
what do you remember listen anywhere you
get your podcasts or watch on youtube